help us change the culture by buying our
latest single from tim cast records only
ever wanted by clicking the link in the
description below
i'm going to jump to the story as kind
of a hard segue postmoniel reports truth
social band from google app store over
content moderation a google sports
spokesperson told
uh said that truth social lacks content
moderation needed to meet google play's
terms of service
according to the hill the spokesperson
said that truth lacks okay so they wrote
that twice
this comes after truth social ceo devin
has claimed last week that the android
version of the uh of the platform's app
is ready waiting only on google's
approval on august 19th we notified
truth social of several violations of
standard policies in their current app
submission and reiterated that having
effective systems for moderating
user-generated content is a condition of
our terms for any app to go live on
google play
google is reportedly particularly
concerned about violations of its
policies prohibiting content with
physical threats and incitement to
violence so this is a really interesting
story because
it's just the next link in the chain of
censorship and if we're talking about
people's ability to learn because of the
internet yeah they're clearly trying to
stop that you well but
the the the thing i thought you were
going towards is
if we're going to have a curriculum on
the internet and they can control what's
in that curriculum then that's just one
more step towards
that
globalist woke nirvana they seemed to we
wanted dragging this entire country down
so so there is that trap yeah
that was a
that was a tough one um whoever whoever
is going to be the next secretary of the
department of education
needs a vision somewhere somewhere along
the line but this bigger issue of the
the social media conglomerates you know
i get back to
the fbi working hand in hand with
twitter
on facebook and by the way there's a
there's a there's a there's a
fascinating funny
tragic story in the taking back trump's
america book as to how twitter and
facebook wound up being so aggressive
against
trump in 2020. i don't know if you guys
know this
but
after
trump won the election in 2016
brad parscale who was at that point
during the 2016 campaign the social
media director he became the campaign
manager in 2020 he goes on 60 minutes
and in the big reveal
as he's claiming victory for the trump
victory through his manipulation social
media he reveals that twitter and
facebook had employees
inside the trump campaign actively
trying to help the trump campaign
message right and as soon as that news
hit all hell broke loose
across this country and particularly in
silicon valley and it was at that point
where
the door jack dorsey at twitter
zuckerberg of facebook
pichai at google said
not in 2020
and and they just they
it's very clear now in hindsight that
social media did everything they could
to skew that election in favor abiding
in against trump
and
that's a really powerful thing and now i
mean this is just this is this is this
is part of why
uh i'll just throw it to andrew
breitbart again pilot
i think he's the one who said politics
is downstream from culture
and then you look at the social media
censorship a large component of that is
inhibiting the ability of a culture to
form and develop banning alex jones
battling banning milo yiannopoulos and
people like laura loomer because they
were influential because they were
having an impact on culture so they had
to be erased
truth social is a really good example
i was saying for a long time that trump
should have gotten off of twitter
launched his own platform or used minds
or gab or something like that and he
didn't do it until recently with the
launch of truth social but this is
actually a good example of probably why
he didn't they just ban the entire app
outright they didn't just ban one person
google said we will ban every single
person all at once
because they want to control what is
allowed to be said and they want to
limit the in the appearance of trump's
influence and culture they don't want
him to be able to influence culture i
would say especially heading into
midterms yep um i i
i'm a big getter fan i call getter the
twitter killer and one of the things
that's been really interesting about
getting on getter it has all the
functionality of twitter with it with a
lot more elegance and live stream
capabilities but what i'll do is i'll
post identical content
on twitter
and on getter and then watch what
happens
and what you see
is the shadow banning that twitter does
you can have the exactly the same amount
of followers
on both platforms
and you get much more social engagement
on getter because of the algorithms that
lay deep inside the twitter
autocracy and you would never
you would never be able to detect that
unless you had
get her
doing the same content yeah i mean it's
really kind of scary right and it's been
interesting a couple of times i've i've
i've tweeted on on
twitter about like okay
about this and you've been getting i
guess the twit sensors are active shadow
banning and for like a little time after
that things got a little better but it's
scary
that
that's the way it works and remember tim
it's like when zuckerberg's talking
about how
he
was able to suppress information
about the hunter biden laptop it was
like he was explaining he did it through
algorithms which would suppress
the
information from coming up to the top
layers so they they know how to do this
and they that's like the the the evil
genius of these people they they really
know
i mean it's this is gobbles
um in the 21st century here they're
really good at what they do that's scary
the way it was explained to me is that
they want to make sure people who
support trump
are still active
because when you censor people it causes
splashes they don't want people to go
together or truth social whatever they
want them to stay where they are
and they're worried that if they make
too big of moves
it will cause a ruckus but they also
want to censor just enough yeah to make
it
to put it uh put it at a disadvantage so
the left wins
so it's basically like you got two
people running a race
one person's pretty fast one person's
kind of slow so what do you do you crack
one person in the foot and then they
can't race as well but they're still
there they're still running but they
just can't make it that's kind of the
idea with how they're handling
censorship
they don't mind certain channels that
exist so long as the more influential
ones get hobbled
i think that's right i think so too
that's right did you always you use
getter as your alternative platform
um
interesting um getter
i think it launched july
uh over a year ago and what what you saw
was was the collapse of
traffic twitter twitter stock
which is really if you look at i mean
twitter's in many ways a dying company
it's like for elon musk to go in and buy
it it's like there were people on my
side of the fence who thought that was a
good idea and oh we're going to liberate
twitter but in fact twitter was dying
okay it's like because because the other
platforms were coming on that that
really did it its job better without the
censorship um
so yeah i don't know how that how that
game
will play out but um it's so the other
thing that that that's so embedded now
if you go to like a newspaper article in
the mainstream media right and you want
to
do something with it
facebook and twitter facebook and
twitter have the monopoly on that so so
that bill so i mean i think we need to
build
an all
an alternative
information infrastructure
that
we can use
uh freely without censorship but boy is
that a lot of work yeah we're building
that now actually well we're building a
lot of stuff i think
oh man it's a depressing monumental task
what it feels like right now because i
can't break up facebook break up
facebook you're gonna facebook messenger
facebook prime instagram you're going to
have all these separate companies
zuckerberg is going to still own them
all he's still going to have all the
code and the monopoly is still going to
be there so i think the only way to do
it or at least the best way to do it is
to make them free their software code
you force them to open up their
algorithms so that other people can not
only watch
what they're shadow banning if they're
shadow banning it what they're tweaking
if they're tweaking but that you can
actually take it and spin up your own
version of the website that
interoperates with their site so like if
i'm on facebook i can see people that
have your version of it if i'm on your
version of it i can see people on
facebook but there's like now there's
competition but it becomes less
competition of code more competition of
terms of service so what system has the
best terms of service which one's
screwing you over the least and people
will migrate there i mean one good thing
about the musk thing is with this
lawsuit
is that he may have subpoena power or
deposition power
to get
to the truth about what they actually do
and that'll be
that'll be fascinating whether he buys
the platform or not yes now in this suit
discovery is a possibility yes yes
they're not going to like that no
they're not going to like that at all
because because they got stuff to hide
yeah he's and he's he's subpoenaed jack
dorsey he's a peanut this whistleblower
i mean whistleblower came out so
even if he doesn't win well actually him
winning means him not buying twitter so
i would hope he loses you know he has to
buy it yeah you wanted to buy it yeah
yeah absolutely i just assume
see uh
see it as road kill on the the getter
and true social super high yeah i think
elon musk taking over be a good thing
though
but uh well let me just in the video
because i've had this debate
um with a couple of pro-musk folks
here's what bothers me about elon musk
and it's it's it's a death blow that sob
took all his money
and went over to communist china
and he's building
teslas yep and his
entire future
is dependent on one whim of xi jinping
okay so he's got to kiss
china's butt every single day of the
week and he does and he does and as long
as he's doing that
that's not good for america and by the
way that's why he's not
as warm to trump okay he he doesn't love
trump because cause because trump is the
one guy he he wants to find he's some
republican he can he can embrace that
won't shut his tesla companies down
these
china the wealthy elites are hedging
their bets with china that's what
they've been doing yeah they've been
buying money putting property there but
it's all basically saying swearing
fealty to xi jinping yes because at any
moment he could take those factories
first snap his fingers i got to talk to
you about repositioning the united
states is the top industrial power on
earth there's i mentioned at the
beginning of the show that we can
recapture carbon from the atmosphere um
we're going to start mining the carbon
dioxide out of the air and the methane
out of the air turning it into carbon
dioxide depositing it onto different
metals palladium gold copper or use it
putting it through other chemicals to
turn it into graphene which is pure
carbon hexagonally latticed
uh like a honeycomb lattice single layer
of carbon pure carbon and it's got it's
conductive like more conductive than
copper it's stronger than steel you can
make touch screen wallpaper out of it
you can make clothing out of it
it's going to be the 21st century
building material and if we start this
mining operation now in the united
states we'll be able to say hey because
what's going to happen is people are
going to start mining it and they're
going to start mining too much if we're
not careful they'll start competing with
the trees and they'll start killing off
the trees because we've taken all the
carbon dioxide too much out so we need
to work with the globe to figure out how
much carbon we're supposed to be putting
out and taking back
but i think it could be a you know
multi-trillion dollar industry at the
very least i don't think it has to be
about money at this point because it's
really about the sustainability and
survival of our species but i think the
united states is the place to build it
i don't know we talked we talked offline
before the show about
the insanity of trying to solve uh the
carbon issue on the demand side
because no matter how much we save here
in the u.s china and india is going to
do more but it's not just go ahead it's
not just that yeah
there's a
there's a mathematical equation that
tracks this if you start to uh let's say
we replace energy uh consumption we
replace our energy sources with nuclear
we start setting up these nuclear power
plants
then you will have people buying
carbon-based you know fossil fuels
for other purposes basically
with cheap energy availability people
still want to grow and expand and use
more energy so if you were to replace
the entire u.s grid with nuclear power
that's great we would reduce our carbon
footprint and then everyone would be
like awesome now the energy is so cheap
i can buy more gas to do these things
so so
so i'm with you on the the what we
should have been doing for a long time
now and haven't been
is working on
carbon capture
ways to do that that that's really the
only
sensible kind of thing and i go back to
my my first job in government
in the 70s is in in the uh
department of energy a summer intern
right and i was like trying to figure
out
how to reduce our oil and import
dependence
on the middle east because it was
causing wars and
embargoes and poverty and all that kind
of stuff like that
never ever did i imagine in the 1970s
could this country ever
become energy independent
but we did that during the trump
administration because of a change in
technology fracking and so
this is how i think we're going to get
out of the the climate change box if you
believe you're we're in one it's that
carbon capture it has to be the only
sensible way to do that otherwise you're
going to force americans to save
you know your
family saves a pound of carbon and
meanwhile the chinese create two two
pounds for every pound we save and they
wind up they wind up being
the leaders of the world uh in the
prosperous country and we can't we can't
have that for a lot of reasons thanks
for checking out this segment from the
tim cast irl podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
monday through friday at 8 p.m and if
you want more special access content
head over to timcast.com and become a
member your membership helps sustain
this company keep our journalists
employed makes this show happen and you
will get access to exclusive members
only segments of the tim cast irl
podcast and there's a massive library to
check out so again go to timcast.com or
tune in monday through friday at 8 pm
and we'll see you all there
you